[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
jean yves le drian testé positif à la
cocaïne le ministre des affaires
étrangères l'a annoncé aujourd'hui sur
son compte twitter à partir
d'aujourd'hui 15 mars à partir de 20
heures un couvre-feu est établi à kiev
le déplacement dans la ville sont
interdits sans laissez-passer spéciaux
puisque la poursuite et l alliance reste
ouverte pour le créneau
besoin de convaincre pendant 20 jours
l'alliance de fermer si elle a surgi
dans l'un des programmes les plus
regardés de russie sur une chaîne
contrôlé par le kremlin pour s'adresser
à son pays arrêtez la guerre ne croyait
pas la propagande on vous ment ici
derrière cette pancarte une journaliste
productrice de la chaîne
marina oficial ico va après ça elle a
été immédiatement arrêtée sans courage
est à la une de plusieurs quotidiens
beaucoup de médias en parlent depuis
malheureusement j'ai travaillé ici pour
la première chaîne et j'ai participé à
la propagande j'ai honte d'avoir permis
la diffusion de ces messages honte
d'avoir laisser transformer les russes
en sont gredins admiration totale devant
le courage devant devant tout ce qu'elle
était capable de faire et vous voyez
qu'une personne peut remuer des
montagnes et elle va remuer des
montagnes elles risquent gros et en plus
le cratère a dénoncé un acte de ce que
j'ai là ajouté et la russie est le pays
agresseur
la responsabilité de cette agression
repose sur la conscience d'un seul homme
et cet homme et de ladignac outin
évidemment nous allons lancer les
démarches diplomatiques visant à offrir
une protection soit l'ambassade soit
aussi une protection résidèrent à votre
confrère je suis reconnaissant envers
les ruses qui essaye de transmettre la
vérité et particulièrement à la femme
qui est entré dans le studio de la
première chaîne russe avec une affiche
contre la guerre on n'a aucune nouvelle
d'elle la promenade est emmené dans un
commissariat
elle est entre les mains des services de
sécurité et où nous risquons nous pas
avoir de nouvelles d'elle pendant de
nombreuse jeux de nombres jour où de
nombreuses semaines au lendemain de son
arrestation marina ou ciani kovar au
sort libre du tribunal
une femme lui crie bravo en russe pour
son courage la diplomatie très peu pour
elon musk dans un tweet le milliardaire
provoque vladimir poutine en duel pour
mettre fin à la guerre en ukraine par la
présente je défie vladimir poutine en
combat singulier l'enjeu c'est l'ukraine
elle dit non ce n'est mais ce n'est pas
une ce n'est pas une campagne et s'il
n'y a pas de campagne la question la
légitimité du gagnant se posera tous les
candidats débattent sauf lui donc
emmanuel macron je n'ai pas entendu
jeudi gérard larcher remettre en cause
la légitimité des présidents de région
et des présidentes de région qui ont été
élu l'an dernier alors même que la
campagne avait été fortement impactée
par la crise qu vide emmanuel macron mal
rasé en jean et souhaite à capuches
siglés cpa 10 un commando d'élite de
parachutistes la dernière série de
clichés publiés par la photographe
officiel de l'elysée sur instagram fait
réagir la le sweat à capuche militaire
la barbe mal rasée qui c'est ridicule
tout ça mais c'est ridicule mais où
est-ce qu'on est là et si pour beaucoup
emmanuel macron se donne la dr de
volodymyr zelensky certains le voient
davantage en prof de paix est une photo
d'ailleurs qui a circulé sur twitter ses
ouailles aussi ce fut chose qui a écrit
notre président il souffre tellement il
travaille aux côtés de geslin ski pour
la paix c'est même remonter jusqu'aux
telegraph anglais qui titre pourquoi la
métamorphose de maquereau en zelensky et
hilarante et erronée les anglais qui
clairement se fout de sa gueule enfin la
tour eiffel culmine désormais à 330 m ce
mardi une antenne radio de six mètres de
haut il a été hélitreuillé c'est la
première fois qu'un nouvel équipement
est installé par hélicoptère sur la tour
eiffel